i tested positive for the coronavirus
and that
is why you didn't hear from me last week
i said i was going to do this podcast
every single monday
we got off to a bit of a rocky start
because during last week's podcast i
actually
had the virus and i didn't know and it
turns out my
pa had the virus my cameraman who's over
there also had the virus my whole team
around me tested positive for the virus
at the same time and none of us knew
and in terms of the experience that i
had with the virus i had one or two
tricky days there was
one day in particular last week where i
had mild flu symptoms
and then i started to get this really
bizarre muscular pain in my back
and i remember it being three or four
a.m in the morning and i'm lying in bed
thinking how do i stop this pain in my
back
and i ordered um ibuprofen and i think
like painkillers on
delivery which were delivered to my door
at 4am
and that night i remember pulling my
pillows off my bed and sleeping on the
floor of my bedroom to try and
straighten out my back
weird symptoms to get i know um but
that's the virus
the symptoms are so unpredictable and
crazy my assistant lost her taste and
smell which is quite a popular one
jack had a bunch of cold symptoms and
things like that as well but
thankfully we all recovered and that
isn't always the case
and a lot of people especially people
that are a little bit more vulnerable
and have
pre-existing conditions aren't always
that lucky
but it made me reflect it made me
reflect on the craziness
of the world right now isn't it nuts
isn't it absolutely bonkers what's
happened over these last seven or eight
months
all of the lockdowns all of the
restrictions the travel restrictions the
the redundancies the the battles the
political battles it's
absolutely crazy it's been the most
crazy seven months of my life without
exception and hard times
as much as they suck in the moment they
teach us important lessons
and there's some lessons which i've
learned more starkly than others which i
wanted to talk about today
the things that i've been writing about
here in my diary and i'm going to start
there this week i'm going to share one
of the key lessons that i've learnt with
you
so without further ado i'm stephen
butler
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody is listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
okay so the first thing in my diary this
week is just a lesson that i've learned
because
of this pandemic and because of all the
restrictions and the lockdowns i've just
written in my diary
learn how to contrast in the right
direction let me explain what i mean
you know i had this moment this week
where i started really thinking about
all of the things that i miss and to be
honest i keep slipping back into these
thoughts
you know in the uk and in the us at the
moment what we're seeing is the
government start to talk about further
restrictions and
returning to the lockdowns that we had
in march and every time i hear these
stories and i go on twitter and i see
the headlines i start to reminisce
over my old life you know and i miss
going to the theater i miss how fun my
weekends with my friends used to be i
miss
you know as a big manchester united fan
i miss going to old trafford and
watching my team play
i miss new york city which is where i
lived before
all of this craziness happened and
before they shut the borders and stopped
me getting back in
i miss speaking on stage i used to
travel around the world
speaking to thousands of people in every
corner of the globe i miss being in the
office
with hundreds of our team members
building the business together i miss
my old life but i'm sure i'm sure that
many of you listening to this have
reminisced over your old life and the
things that you miss
in the last few weeks and months pretty
you know
unavoidably and typically when we
do this in a more subconscious way
without really thinking about it
we arrive at a place of sadness a place
of
self-pity a place of grief at least i
know i did
you know and i almost honestly
this is kind of embarrassing to admit
you'll understand why i think this is
embarrassing now that i say it
i almost started feeling sorry for
myself and this
for the love of god is why you have to
interrogate your own thinking
and let me just interrogate exactly what
i've just said to you about all of the
things i miss and let me
try and reframe all of those things
through another perspective
when this global pandemic happened i was
a 27 year old guy
who was able to go to the theater go to
old trafford and watch my favorite team
play
whenever i wanted to i lived in a
beautiful apartment in new york city
eating at the best restaurants in the
world
traveling around the world in business
class getting paid to speak to thousands
of people on stage whilst running a
global business that was full of my
friends
the thing that took me from that is a
global pandemic which has killed
over a million people and it's
devastated people's livelihoods it
stripped them of their
generational family businesses and it's
plunged them into desperation
right now many people can't even pay the
bills
feed their kids many people can't even
bear the thought of their future
meanwhile all of my family are healthy i
have work
i have freedom i can feed myself right
now there are more people than
ever praying for the family praying for
the health praying for the opportunities
and praying for the life
that i have right now and that you have
right now
and then and when you start to think
about it like that
it changes things and if you think about
it like that you'll probably arrive at
the conclusion that 2020
shouldn't make you feel sorry for
yourself it should make you feel so
unbelievably grateful
and this is the power of contrast when
you contrast your life in the wrong
direction you can make yourself
miserable like i did
you know i was on the verge of wallowing
in self-pity because i couldn't go to
the
theater anymore because i couldn't go to
old trafford and watch my
because i didn't get on business class
flights and get to fly to every corner
of the world
even [ __ ] privileged [ __ ] like me
can make the mistake
right so i can't imagine how easy it is
to make this mistake for everybody else
when you contrast your life
up as i was doing to the life you had
back in march
to someone more fortunate than you to
someone that's prettier than you on
instagram or to someone that looks more
successful
than you from the outside you'll quickly
arrive at a place of self-pity
and ungratefulness which is the quickest
way to unhappiness
but if you contrast your life down to
the billions and billions of people that
would do anything to be in your shoes
that would do anything to have the
health of their sick parents back
to have a warm home to have a fridge
full of food to have a secure job
then you'll arrive at gratitude and
honestly gratitude in my life has been
one of the best ways i've
ever known to be happy the world we see
and how we see it is a direct result of
contrast
and the contrast games that you play
every day if you
stroll through the corridor of a
hospital and you peer into the
the wards and you peer in and look at
the different patients
what you'll see is people sick and
suffering and in some cases
unfortunately dying
and suddenly because of that contrast
you'll feel so grateful for your good
health and we i do this all the time
you know i had this problem a couple
years ago with one of my ears where i
woke up one day and there was this faint
ringing sound in my right ear and at
first i thought it was nothing i thought
it would pass
but after two days my ear was still
ringing i go on google i google it
comes up as something called tinnitus or
tinnitus right and it and i'm reading
through these forums of people saying
that they've had it for their entire
lives it came out of nowhere and it
ruined their lives
it stopped them from sleeping it made
them depressed it stopped them from
focusing
it fundamentally changed their lives and
after 10 days of my ear just ringing
non-stop
faintly i came to terms with the fact
that i was gonna have this for the rest
of my life
and i couldn't stop thinking about it
because when your ears always ringing
it's hard
to ignore right and i couldn't sleep
properly and i started to worry
and in that moment after two weeks of
one of my ears ringing
i can't tell you how much i
longed and wished for my normal hearing
back
for just normal ears for that ringing to
cease and it made me feel so ungrateful
that it took an element where my ear
would just ring constantly for me to
suddenly feel grateful for
my eyesight my ears the fact that i can
walk that i have ten fingers that i can
think
and that's the way that contrasts work
you know the same applies for the
technology in our lives those old
nokia brick phones were the best thing
ever in a world
that didn't have the iphone in it and
your life right now
in the midst of the pandemic in what
month are we in october
is such an amazing privileged life
in a world where you can't remember your
old one the one you had back in march
this year taught me that the grass will
always look
greener on the other side until you
start watering the side that you're on
right now and that's really all you can
do
contrasting up is just such a deadly sin
that we all need to avoid especially in
moments like this
we all have to be aware conscious and
mindful of how we're contrasting because
the world is a crazy place and there's
no guarantee that it's not going to get
crazier right
and if you continue to contrast up
you'll contrast
yourself into depression and despair and
misery and self-pity
like i nearly did like i nearly did when
i started reflecting on my old life and
telling myself all of all of the things
that i missed not the things that i have
having control of your contrast can
fundamentally change the way you see the
world and if it can change the way you
see the world
it can change how you feel and if it can
change how you feel then
it can change your life let's move on
i have a secret to tell you and this is
the second point in my diary this week
it's a secret that i only found out
and started to deeply understand
recently when i say recently i mean
the last 24 months it's a secret that i
really started to understand
honestly being completely honest with
you when i got rich and when i got
rich friends and those rich friends
pulled back
a certain curtain and allowed me to see
behind it i'd always heard about this
i'd always heard that there's
another curtain i heard joe rogan did a
a podcast with um
kevin hart and on the podcast kevin hart
talks about meeting jeff bezos and
realizing that there's this other
level there's this other curtain which
some people have access to
and the more wealthy that i got and the
more you know wealthy people that
started to
to surround me i started to understand
what kevin hart meant
and i started to understand what that
secret is here is the secret
access to information and
information itself that is the real
privilege in this world that's the thing
if your rich parent gives you money
that's like them giving you a fish right
but if they
pull you into the family business and
show you how it works
they're giving you a fishing rod money
is efficient life and information is a
fishing rod and only one of those things
will feed you for a lifetime
and when you get to the level that i'm
at now and you have access to a new
level of information you're
associating with a different level of
person
you realize how much you didn't know
before and you didn't know
because you don't know what you don't
know it they are unknown unknowns
and so back then i was kind of naive i
just thought i knew
everything and where i'm at now i
started to wonder
why no one told me this stuff the stuff
i know now about wealth and finance and
about how these systems work
and you start to realize why the rich
get richer and why the poor
stay poor information and access to
information obviously there's a ton of
systemic issues which are controlling
things but for me
information and access to information is
the single biggest one
when i made my first million i started
studying wealth right and i started
studying investing in finance and i
started to get really obsessed with how
i could turn the money i had into a lot
more money
i started speaking to more millionaires
and billionaires i started spending more
time with billionaires and i got to see
what i refer to to my close friends as
money games
the games that they play and how they
double triple and quadruple their money
just by having certain information and
this is information that most of us
don't have we aren't given we aren't let
in we aren't allowed to see behind the
curtain
and these are games that i never knew
when i was broke games they didn't teach
you
or me in school games that really rich
people have no incentive to teach you
because they're too
busy playing them the people that sell
money and those finance courses on
instagram they aren't rich
right they're selling new courses on
instagram if they knew a better way to
make money they wouldn't be
spending their time selling you courses
on instagram but there's another level
there's another level of information
which is what i think kevin hart was
referring to when he spoke about being
able to peer in behind the
curtain and you know i'm gonna really
disappoint you here after what was
probably one of the biggest
build ups that i've ever done on this
podcast because i don't have enough
time in the hour or so that we have on
this podcast to teach you everything
that i've come to learn
and to be honest even if i did i don't
think that's the most
valuable thing that i could give you in
this hour that we have together today
just like money is a fish right me
telling you today's information is also
a bit of a fish
because things change quite quickly in
the world and even if i could tell you
everything i knew now
about money games it would at some point
expire
it would very quickly change i think the
most valuable
important fishing rod that i could give
you in this hour is in fact a change of
mindset
i think if i can get you to realize that
your monetary
future value and how rich you'll be in
your life is perhaps somewhat equal to
the value of the information you have in
your brain
then maybe maybe just maybe you'll start
to value information and learning and
the pursuit of knowledge
even more and in the world we live in we
all have
access to the to the same information
pretty much
but most of us still don't understand
the true value of it
one of the greatest privileges i think i
could ever give to my future kids
is to teach them the value of learning
gaining experience acquiring information
and
self-education which is something we can
all do now because we all have google
right we all have the internet we all
have social media we will have youtube
you know you're doing it right now some
of you that are watching this online i
think we tend to
over value short-term financial
incentives and
undervalue learning opportunities which
will give us that long-term value
advantage
and all of the young people and even
some of the slightly old people that i
get a chance to mentor
this is one of the key lessons i try and
teach them is to be able to spot
short-term value from long-term value
you know and i'm going to go off peace
just a little bit here and i'm going to
tell you a bit of a personal story
um that happened to me actually quite
recently uh and this is the you know
this podcast is the home of the truth so
make sure you do keep this to yourself i
had a a young person
in their early 20s asked to come and
work with me and when i say work with me
i don't mean
you know in the same building as me i
mean with me and because of the
lockdowns and the way the world is
all of my sort of real close team are
literally working with me in my home
or in you know in a small um co-working
space and
this was a in my opinion a fairly unique
opportunity right because we're gonna be
sat together pretty much every day
and they were so persistent that
eventually i ended up offering them
a job and i offered them a job on the
same salary the same wage that they're
earning right now in their current role
and i offered them a guaranteed pay rise
in 60 days time and they effectively
turned the offer down because they
wanted a little bit more money now
and whatever i say from this point
onwards is going to sound petty
and biased and bitter i have no other
way of saying it i'm just gonna be
honest with you
honestly from what i know about their
situation
and from what i know about where they
wanted to go in their career and as
impartially as i could possibly be
that was a [ __ ] stupid decision just
just purely based on the fact
that if you sit next to me or someone
that's fortunate enough to have the
access to the
level of information that i have access
to someone that is willing to give you
that information
and information that's probably going to
help you fulfill the goals that you have
[ __ ] a 2k pay rise that information can
quite
literally make you a millionaire too and
i've seen it make people
millionaires you know much of the reason
why i'm sat here as a millionaire
is because i got to sit next to people
who had gone on the journey that i
wanted to go on
and that's what i mean we tend to
overvalue the short-term financial
incentives and undervalue the learning
opportunities which will give us
long-term value knowing how to make spot
the difference and knowing which is
which will change your life
and sometimes you have to play a long
game you have to delay that
gratification you have to hold off on
that
2k pay rise because the situation you're
in is giving you
real long-term value your long-term
future will be better
if you make long-term decisions or your
life will be slightly better in the
short term if you make short-term
decisions but then your long-term future
is compromised and that's what delaying
gratification is you have to learn to do
that in your careers too
i'm gonna close off this point by
telling you the easiest
simplest change that i've made in my
life to radically radically increase
the amount of information and the amount
of good quality information that i'm
exposed to
one small change but before i tell you
we're going to play a little game
just imagine for a second that you could
pick up an imaginary phone in front of
you and you could just
listen in to the world's smartest minds
the world's smartest minds in
in fitness in business in finance
spirituality and philosophy just imagine
imagine if you could be a fly on the
wall as they discuss
ideas as they seek to understand the
world and as they
talk about what they know and as they
play their money games and enrich
themselves imagine how transformative
that would be
imagine how much that information would
change your life it would change your
health
your happiness and probably your wealth
and imagine if all of that
that access to information was free
it is free that's twitter that's social
media
that's youtube you can literally watch
and listen to the smartest people in the
world
think discuss and ideate so that's big
the question you have to be honest
why the [ __ ] do you still follow jenny
from 10 years ago who you do not give a
f
about as she publicly complains to some
customer service rep on twitter
about her t-mobile data plan being
expensive and slow or
kylie jenner as she publicly advertises
the results of her
plastic surgery and demolishes your
self-esteem in the process all that
clown on facebook that tries to convince
you that 5g internet
the coronavirus and bill gates were all
part of some illuminati conspiracy
theory
why are you choosing that information
why are you allowing
junk to seep into your mental diet where
is that information going to take you
information is the privilege and you
have to be the gatekeeper
and the unapologetic defender of the
information that you consume
i've said this before and in fact it's
proven to be so important in my life
that i'm gonna keep saying it until
i feel like you're listening to me who
you follow online especially if you're
someone that spends hours of day
on the internet and social media like i
do is the single biggest
influence on your life for the love of
god
follow better and unfollow faster
my trick which i'm going to give to you
is i basically mute
everyone 90 of the people on my
instagram are muted probably near 95
percent
i just don't see their stuff i don't see
their stories i don't see their posts
because usually it's actually not that
helpful to me
50 of the people on my twitter are muted
and i'm muting people because
just like you there are real world
consequences of you know unfollowing
friends and people and family and things
like that so i just mute them
it's a nice middle ground where they
don't know and they don't need to know
right
and if i start talking [ __ ] online i
give you permission to unfollow me to
please subscribe to this podcast but i
give you permission to unfollow me too
and this has changed my life honestly
it's the simplest thing the simplest
decision
that has had the single biggest impact
on my life i'm
definitely smarter happier and more
professionally capable because of it
so if there is a small thing that you
can do now to really change the most
important influence on your life it's to
go through your social media timelines
and
every time you see someone who isn't
contributing
towards the values or the information
that you want to consume
boom mew but and here comes a very
important caveat you have to be careful
not to unfollow or mute people just
because they disagree with your opinion
a few years ago if i saw someone in my
timeline that overtly supported like a
different political party
or had a completely opposing opinion to
mine all just like strongly disagreed
with issues that i really care about
i would just unfollow them boom bye
felicia and i think i did that because i
didn't want to feel the frustration that
i felt when i logged in
and saw their posts and tweets and also
i didn't want to keep biting and arguing
and debating with them online
but when you think about that decision
logically it's a pretty terrible
decision
all i'm doing by doing that is narrowing
my world view
and i'm building reinforcing this echo
chamber around me
which is full of people who believe
everything i already believe
and the fundamental truth that we all
have to have the intellectual strength
to believe
is that often there really is no right
or wrong
everything is really just a bunch of
perspectives that's what the world is
full of
very very few things are a case of right
or wrong we'll probably all agree that
the sky is blue
but as it relates to the way the world
should be run our political opinions how
people should be treated
there's typically quite a lot of
variants and
those perspectives that perfectly agree
with yours are actually
the least valuable they're not going to
challenge you or broaden your
perspective or teach you anything
only the perspectives that differ from
yours can do that
whether they differ because they're you
know a little bit more developed on your
opinions or
because they disagree but it's not easy
and i'd be lying to you if i pretend
that it was i've
genuinely and i this is a weekly battle
i've genuinely struggled to keep people
on my social media timelines within my
social media bubble
that say things i really disagree with
and that support ideas that i despise
but i also think if i'm being completely
honest with myself
i'm better off because of it listen i'm
not i'm not going to let ryan on
facebook tell me that 5g internet caused
coronavirus
but i am going to fill my social bubble
and my circle online
with people who honestly disagree people
who can respectfully
explain why they disagree and people who
view the world differently to me
you know i i hope this is the last time
that i make this point
on this podcast but it just keeps coming
to the front of my mind so if you've not
cleansed your social media following
please do it now i really really hope
this is the last time i feel like
if i can convince you to do this now
today this week
it will be for some of you the greatest
thing i was
ever able to do for you the greatest
gift i can give you for listening to
this podcast
also you know turn all the unifications
off all of them
but we'll save that topic for another
time
okay so the third point in my diary is
about changing the shape of your brain
you can change the shape of your brain
what a load of nonsense over the
over the last couple of years i've heard
a lot of people people that i respect a
lot
including tom bill you who came on this
podcast tell me
that you can quite literally change the
shape of your brain
and at first i'll be honest i thought
this was potentially some
you know some of that self-development
fluff and nonsense that we read a lot
about you know the
hocus pocus nonsense [ __ ] um and i
thought to myself how could you possibly
change the shape and composition of your
brain
without having some type of evasive
surgery but i hold my hands up it turns
out i was wrong and i wasn't just a
little bit wrong i was really really
really really wrong
over the last few months as i've gone on
the journey of writing my book which is
coming out called happy sexy millionaire
the unexpected truth about fulfillment
love and success which you can get right
now on amazon
i started to develop a bit of an
obsession
with neuroscience and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna go do too deep into the
science because you don't necessarily
need to know that stuff
but i'm to tell you about some of the
things that i learned on that journey
and particularly one thing that changed
my life
and here it is our brains are malleable
just like play-doh and our experiences
determine their shape
this process is almost best compared to
physical exercise where
you know 30 reps today isn't going to
make you super muscular and big right
but 30 reps every day for a year will
and the same is true for your brain the
science says that whatever you focus
your mind upon be
anger or self-doubt or fear your brain
will eventually
literally change in shape and i sound
like i'm talking nonsense i can hear
myself saying this it sounds like
some hocus-pocus magic but i promise you
this is the truth
and listen i'm if you know me you know
i'm just as immune to self-development
nonsense and fluff as you are so i only
share things with you that i think are
fundamentally true and that's supported
by some kind of evidence let me give you
an example if you're a compulsive
warrior the science shows that your
brain will quite literally change
to become a finely tuned anxiety and
worry machine you'll get your brain will
become
tuned for worry and i've looked through
the research i've looked at before and
after pictures of brain scans of people
who've overcome
worry and addiction and negative
thinking about themselves and other more
serious psychological conditions and
honestly blew my socks off
i've always believed that we are you
know we are what we think
but the science shows us that we quite
literally from a neurological
perspective
become what we think you know i read
this great piece
online by this neurological expert
called brian penny and he has this lab
where they've worked on being able to
predict the age of your brain just by
looking at it on brain scans
and your brain age is associated with
increased mortality risk cognitive
decline
increased risk of dementia and overall
general
poorer physical functioning they can
literally see
how a life change that you make a
decision you make in your life will
change the shape of your brain over a
number of years
they can see how a person that gives up
x y or zed
then has a completely different brain
just a few years later
just like how if you stopped going to
the gym or you started going to the gym
you'd have a completely different body a
few years later
and they've identified a number of
methods just
simple everyday choices and cognitive
tools that science suggests
can positively change the shape of your
brain i'm just going to tell you about
one of them today and it's the one that
fascinated me the most
it's called observation without
engagement
this is basically what they call
self-observation which is a
pretty big part of meditation if you've
ever meditated you'll understand this
and it really helps you do exactly that
it involves like mindfully observing
your thoughts and your feelings and your
bodily sensations
the best example i can give you is you
know if i asked you to observe
right now how how tense your body feels
instantly you might you know take a step
back and start focusing on your sore toe
or the tightness in your chest or that
headache
which you didn't notice before but you
can only notice when you start to
observe yourself
if i ask you to observe your thoughts
and your feelings you can also do that
too you might start to think about
the things you're worrying about or that
particular unsolved situation in your
life or about your family's health
because of this virus
the things that are going on
subconsciously which you didn't really
notice
about that big decision on your future
which you're procrastinating making
the point is you can take an observer's
perspective
on your anxious thoughts on your
feelings and on your bodily sensations
you don't have to try and live inside of
the problem all the time you don't have
to live inside of your feelings or your
emotions
and when you do this don't try and
engage you're not supposed to try and
fix it just
observe let me give you another metaphor
which i think explains this best it's
called the clouds metaphor
imagine your thoughts and feelings or
bodily sensations
as just clouds that are floating through
the sky and sometimes those clouds are
dark sometimes they're
angry sometimes it's you know raining
and sometimes they're light and
sometimes they're calm and thin
but you're not the clouds you're the
blue sky who just observes the clouds as
they're passing without engaging in them
you simply
observe and you let them pass you by and
as the 20-something ceo of a big
company who knows that every time i look
at my emails and my whatsapp in the
morning there's gonna be
a ton of unpredictable yet unfortunately
inevitable [ __ ] not just small
[ __ ] severe [ __ ] i'm talking
ruin your day [ __ ]
[ __ ] that can rear its head from any
corner or person
in a global business of 700 people as as
that guy
this mechanism has quite literally saved
me i really really believe that and from
my conversations with dom
who's my business partner who's been
with me this whole time you know which i
had on this podcast in chapter 10 where
he described that running the business
made him an alcoholic made him anxious
and made him
experience some pretty severe mental
health problems i genuinely believe
that this this technique was the
fundamental difference between me and
him
self-observation which is something that
for some reason i've always defaulted to
we both had the same intense stressful
experience over the last 10 years
but in his words i survived it and he
nearly didn't
he said right and this is a horrible
thing for me to talk about he said
he considered jumping in front of a
train and killing himself
because things at one point were so
almost unbearable
and the difference is here it's in your
mind and the mechanisms you rely on to
deal with your portion of unpredictable
life [ __ ] which is coming your way
whether you like it or not
i've said in this podcast before that i
viewed the hardest moments in my life as
as
really a video game i naturally and
again
i don't want to take too much credit for
this because it's not something that i
did consciously i naturally adopted this
strange
video game mindset where i would almost
see
the situation i was in like a game of
chess like i was removed
from it when things got really really
hard i told myself without thinking
about it
that this was all just a game yeah like
a like a game of chess
and i'm not the pieces on the chessboard
because they can be killed i'm the
person responsible for moving the pieces
and whatever happens i'll be fine just
like
you know like a game of call of duty i'm
not the character in the screen running
with the gun
the one at danger of standing on a land
mine i'm the person holding the
controller sat at home
and even if i stand on a land mine or
two that's fine i can just
restart and rejuvenate and you know go
again
and for me this perspective which is
very similar to what i've described with
this self-observation
was the most liberating thing in my
whole career it allowed me to develop my
own calm within any form of chaos and it
allowed me
to think clearly without being clouded
by emotion and if you're
a ceo if you're running a business
that's so incredibly important
and i genuinely also think that my
business partner don was inside the game
he was the pawn on the chessboard he was
the soldier running through the
battlefield in the call of duty he was
taking
the enemy fire so he internalized that
pain he internalized the stress and he
became the conflict
and honestly nobody can survive that
nobody not even me
but fortunately for whatever reason i
was removing myself
and that helped self-observation isn't
just handy for
increasing your like self-awareness it
genuinely provides you with a sense of
detachment in the most
challenging situations you'll find
yourself in instead of being controlled
by the situation and the thoughts that
come with the situation
and all of those feelings it gave you
gives you this ability to
hold out in front of you to observe it
and to let it come
and to let it go without impacting you
too much
and the brain research they've done on
this topic completely supports this
they've studied the part of your brain
that becomes active
when you're drifting from thought to
thought and overthinking and worrying
and they've seen clearly how this can
have a detrimental impact on your
personal well-being
and over a number of years the shape of
your brain
they've then also observed how that
attachment which you can achieve from
self-observation and that video game
mindset where
you become the sky not the clouds can
quiet that part of your brain
and there's one particular study that
shows that people who meditate have
reduced activity
in that part of their brain versus
people that don't meditate
and listen when we talk about meditation
i was a bit of a skeptic on the whole
topic
meditation doesn't have to be sitting
with your legs crossed
humming to yourself right it can
literally just be taking a few minutes
out to relax
and pause and for me meditation is
usually in the form of a massage it's
the time where
i can stop i can pause and i can detach
and that for me is crucial crucial
crucial for
everybody no matter what walk of life
you're in you have to find your paws
and listen this isn't going to stop you
getting anxious or worried or stressed
but
learning the habit of self-observation
and that video game mindset and becoming
the sky as i'll call it
will allow your problems to come go and
limit the impact they have on you
without having to always engage in them
and therefore
making them worse than they have to be
without making a mountain
out of what could have just been a
molehill
for the next point in my diary i've just
written less answers and more
questions you know so much of the the
self-development career progression
advice that i got when i was younger
told me to speak up more
you know make sure i'm heard and to get
my point across whenever i can and i'm
telling you
the older i've got and the further i've
traveled in the business world the more
i've learned that that's really
shitty advice in the real world it's
impressive
to know an answer of course but it's
also impressive to admit that you don't
it's impressive to say and to have the
sense of yourself to say
i don't know to say you're probably
right to say
that's not my area of expertise to say i
don't know but i'm going to find out or
just to remain silent the least
impressive thing you can do is
speak for the sake of speaking we all
know people like this and they typically
do that because they are insecure
and because they think if they have
nothing to say then they're not very
valuable
we all have this contribution reputation
let me call it a contribution score
you won't know what your contribution
score is but you'll probably know the
score of the people around you the
people in your friendship groups and in
your family
you'll know that person within your
friendship group or a colleague at work
that just seems to speak for the sake of
speaking and most of the time
when they add something to the
conversation people kind of like roll
their eyes and
you know and they think to themselves
that was a really dumb thing to say
and it gets to the point that before
they speak everyone in the room presumes
it's going to be something dumb again or
weird or
unhelpful or irrelevant i think you'll
know that person
and that is because their contribution
score is low
that is what a contribution score is it
really really matters because if you
constantly speak
for the sake of speaking or you you know
you speak when you're not informed on a
topic
people will gradually stop listening to
you they will receive your id
ideas with a pre-conceived bias
that you're probably going to say
something that doesn't matter and so
your ideas suffer
even if they're good because of that
preconceived bias and that preconceived
opinion of what you have to say
so even when you do have something
valuable to add
everybody will disregard it they'll
pre-devalue it
before it's even come out of your mouth
and that's because just like a credit
score we all have a contribution score
and in that case it's because you've
ruined yours by always feeling the need
to chime in
even when you don't know what you're
talking about even when you shouldn't
if you don't know the answer to
something at least know the value of
admitting that you don't
or staying quiet as someone that's you
know had the pleasure and sometimes
displeasure of working in boardrooms and
in creative brainstorms
and in intense investor meetings with
big personalities and sometimes
competitive personalities for the last
decade i've seen how someone
you know can ruin their contribution
score by constantly feeling the need to
say something or add something when they
don't know the answer
and when this isn't their field of
expertise and i've also seen the
opposite i've seen people who will sit
and listen humbly and just observe and
often
learn and the people that walk out of
the room with their respect and
contribution score intact to always
those that are secure enough to admit
that they
don't know and to in many cases stay
quiet and the ones that lose respect
are those that try and pretend they know
something that isn't in their field of
expertise
or that they know something about
usually because they're insecure and
this is why as a general rule for life
it's always better to have more
questions than you have answers and to
be able to admit
when you don't have the answers your
contribution score really really matters
and i think you come to learn that the
further you go
in your career it's the thing that for
me made investors believe me
you know this this notion i think they
have in their head which is when stephen
speaks
it's probably something informed and
something worth listening to
it's the things that you know makes
employees trust you as a ceo
it's a thing that as a colleague earns
respect
and ultimately if you have the humility
to learn to listen
in areas that are outside your expertise
it'll be the thing that expands your
knowledge
and again that that will change your
life
and this brings me to the next point in
my diary and i've written in my diary
what are some of the most important
questions
i ask myself regularly and i when i say
this i mean in all areas of my life
if it's more important to know the right
question to ask them to have the answer
what are the questions that you should
ask yourself every single day
and um the first one in my diary
is which part of this situation can i
control you know as a ceo but just as a
human being that's living life like we
all are
there are so many times where i
encounter a situation of conflict or
stress or chaos
um and i'm desperate to fix it and i
start committing
energy to trying to solve the problem
usually
and this is something that i've come to
learn there's really only like three or
four things that i can control in this
situation
and if i know what those things are i
can
invest my energy in those levers in
pulling those levers
and that gives me the best chance of
getting out of the situation
it also is a great tool for liberating
yourself from all of the stress
of worrying about things that are
completely outside of your control and
that you can do nothing about
and i've done this over the last two
years in particular where i will hone in
and i will sometimes even write in my
diary the two or three things in the
situation i'm in now that i that i can
control
gives me that clarity it liberates me
from stress and it focuses me
on the things that will actually help me
get out of the situation
i'm in and the second question which i
ask myself religiously at least once a
day
and is actually held as a permanent
point on my to-do list
is what am i avoiding right now this is
something that i
i dare you to try and ask yourself every
day because for me
understanding what i'm avoiding helps me
overcome it and as near ielts said on
this podcast we are creatures that
seek to avoid discomfort so there's
nearly always a reason
why i'm procrastinating or avoiding
something and if i can become
conscious about that thing and the
psychological discomfort that's
making me avoid it it helps me to
overcome it and usually the things we
avoid are actually really really
important
and that's part of the reason they're
causing us discomfort so that's a
question that i recommend
everybody asks themselves every day make
a list of the things you want to ask
yourself the first is what part of this
situation can i control
and the second is what am i avoiding the
third is what would my idols think about
this decision and this is a question
which i religiously ask myself when i'm
facing
a big life choice because i think we all
understand the values and the principles
that our idols lived by we study you
know we study their lives we
read their books their podcasts whatever
we understand the way that they think
but when we're in a situation when we're
facing a big decision
sometimes we kind of relapse back to
our own innate fear-driven
decision-making mechanisms
and we lose sight of how our idols the
people we want to be like
would make that decision so every time i
make a big
life decision i almost like interrogate
it against what i know that my idols
would do because my idols are my idols
because they have
values that i admire and so if i can
kind of
sense check my own decision-making
against what i think they would do which
is sometimes
easier than knowing the right thing to
do i tend to make a better decision
and the next question i religiously ask
myself is what would future steve think
of this decision
and this question is super handy to ask
yourself whenever you can
because future you is going to pay the
price for the decisions you make today
so future you is quite a selfish person
they want to be they want to have a
six-pack they want to be super smart
they want to be rich
and that is almost all of our north star
our future self
and so if you ask yourself genuinely ask
yourself the question
what would future steve the happiest
version the best version of me
think about this decision i'm about to
make to eat this entire
double pizza to myself
usually that allows you to see if this
decision you're about to make is in line
with your values
and the next question that i like to ask
myself regularly
is if i'm saying yes to this thing then
what am i saying no to
i think it was steve jobs who once said
that it's only by saying no to things
that you can concentrate on what's
important in your life
and i love this line because it really
helped me to realize the potency of that
question
be it in our relationships or our career
or in our health or in our mental health
um i think it's important and i think we
need to reflect on what we hold most
dear
now in this moment in order to live a
life and to attain a future
that is in line with our values and we
need to become aware of how a yes
decision is going to prevent us from
doing other things
that we also consider to be relatively
important it's a question that
appreciates
that you can't do everything and be
everything and that life is about
prioritization
prioritizing the things that are most
important and so before i say yes to
something
i like to consider all of the things
that i'm saying no to as a consequence
of that yes it helps me to make better
decisions today
and it's a sign a signal and a nod
to how much i respect the limited amount
of time i have
and the last question which i've written
in my diary
that i ask myself religiously is a much
more direct question which is
does this thing align with my values you
know people often make decisions that
don't
align with their values i know that i do
it every day and there are
tons of reasons people do this you know
they uh they binge on alcohol
they they smoke 20 cigarettes a day they
have
big mac you can't have a big mac pizza
they have big mac burgers and domino's
pizzas
religiously even though they know that
their future values of health and being
around to see their kids grow up
and those kinds of things are in
conflict with those short-term
detrimental actions
and often we do this because we don't
stop to ask ourselves this simple
question and we don't really stop to
think about this simple question
which is how does this short-term
decision
align with my long-term values next time
you're doing something
and it doesn't feel quite right and it
feels a little bit naughty ask yourself
how it's serving
what you value most in life and that
having you know
the obsession i have now with
continually cross-checking
the decisions i'm about to make versus
the person i want to be or the life i
want to attain
has been transformative for me honestly
it's really really changed my life
and i'm going to throw in a bonus
question i did say that was the last one
but i'm going to give you a bonus
question which i've just
i've just been thinking about it's a
little bit cliche but i promise you it's
helped me
overcome you know some of the most
fearful moments of my life
the question is what's the worst that
will happen if i attempt this and i
remember being
really really young 16 years old when
someone first asked me to speak on stage
and then 17 and then 18 and then the
stage is getting bigger and the audience
is getting bigger i remember one day
speaking in barcelona in front of about
10
000 people and being stood backstage and
starting to feel a little bit of that
anxiety which we all feel
and i i for some reason just like the
video game mindset which i've talked
about in this podcast
i default to asking myself what is the
worst thing that can happen
and i don't just ask myself that
question in the cliche way that friend
might turn to you and say
i genuinely run through the process of
what you know
what is the worst thing that can happen
i could walk up on stage and as i'm
walking on stage
i trip on the first step i fall i smash
my face
my trousers come down people see my
underwear and my you know my willy
and i walk up on stage and then i
deliver the worst speech in my life
and people start walking out and
throwing stuff at me and i walk off
stage and
and to be honest it's nearly always the
case that the worst thing that can
happen
isn't actually as bad as you think we
tend to you know before we
confront it and rationalize it that way
and look at it in that way
we tend to i guess think it's death i
think i think we think we're gonna die
and everyone's gonna hate us and
and then you ask yourself this sub
question which is if the worst thing
that i think could happen happens what
is the long-term impact of that on my
life
and even if i fell on the step hit my
you know hit my eye
walked on stage with a bleeding eye and
then did the worst speech of my life
it doesn't actually have any long-term
impact on my life okay i wouldn't get
booked to speak there again but the
the material long-term impact of my life
is pretty much
nil and so it doesn't make sense to be
fearful because the
worst possible outcome has no long
long-term impact on your life
and for me that's the question that i
really hold dear and it's a question
that i still turn to
in moments of intense pressure and fear
um fear of failure and i think it's a
question that can change your life
if you're a very fearful person those
are my questions
and i i am i think it's important to
have questions and be armed with
questions because as i
say in life it turns out that having the
questions is much more important than
having all the answers
okay so the last point in my diary this
week is it's just a sentence and i'm
going to read that sentence to you
the thing that invalidates you when
you're younger will be the things you
seek validation from when you're an
adult and this is um
this is something that it really took me
about 30 years the 28 years i've been
alive to learn
um when i was younger as a lot of you
will know if you've listened to this
podcast before
i came from a background in a family
that didn't have a whole lot of
money right we were pretty much bankrupt
for my whole
um my whole childhood at least the last
part of my my
my time living at home we lived in a
house that was beat up
um the window on the front of our house
was smashed for a good decade so
you know you'd get the draught coming in
from outside we live my back garden
the grass in the background is about six
foot high and there are fridges and
tv sets and all kinds of nonsense in
there in fact the back half of my house
was actually knocked down because i
think at one point my mom thought we had
the money to do a renovation
but we didn't have the money so they
just the builders just knocked the house
down and just left it as a derelict
house so one of the the doors you know
which used to go into one of the rooms
was actually would just actually take
you outside
and we just removed the handle so that
no one could really break into our house
the front of our house was the same we
had you know the grass was
you know a good meter and a half high at
times and it was
fairly embarrassing um growing up as a
black kid in an all-white school who
already felt a little bit different
with my curly hair knowing that our
house also looked so
marked you know remarkably different and
that my life was remarkably different
from a financial perspective we didn't
have
um christmases and birthdays by the time
i was about 10 10 11 years old because
of the financial situation we're in
and i know that it created a real deep
insecurity within me i remember
christmas days
sat in my brother kevin's room on the
floor as we joked about the things we
were going to pretend we got for
christmas
you know like and i have to make i have
to to bring
context to this right like i know now as
an adult
that this was a terribly naive selfish
immature way to think
i know now that i should have been
looking at all the things i did have
which was a loving family
two parents that were together and loved
me a roof over my head
food on the table i know now that those
were the important things but back then
when you're a young little kid who
doesn't really understand the world you
feel sorry for yourself
you engage in self-pity and i did and i
would go to school embarrassed and i
would go to school and lie
about our financial situation and it
made me insecure it invalidated me
you know it was one of the the biggest
worries or you know
insecurities i had as a kid and so at 14
years old i started to
really really value money money for me
just felt so important
the lack of money we had in our life was
the reason that i had so much shame it
was the reason that
my mum and dad would scream at each
other so much about
our house and about our finances and
about christmas
and about all of these other things and
money was the problem so i grew up
thinking
and pretty obsessed with attaining money
or if i went to university at 18 years
old dropped out started a business to
try and make loads of money
and then when i finally got money set 21
22 years old
i had a really unhealthy relationship
with it
and i went to nightclubs and i spent i
think one year like 50 60
000 pounds on champagne in a nightclub
at 22 23 years old
just to try and impress people and then
i went out to the countryside and bought
this seven bedroom mansion with a
tennis court at the bottom of the garden
and two living rooms and an outhouse and
big gates and a 100 meter driveway
just to try and impress people and this
is
this is a force in our lives which will
ruin our lives
if we don't understand it and the thing
that i came to learn after literally
like 25 years
and after being a puppet you know the
puppet master being this thing that
happened to me as a kid
after being a puppet that didn't know
why he was doing what he was doing but
was just buying these tables and
nightclubs and
buying material things and trying to
show off to people
i came to learn that the thing that
invalidated me when i was younger
had become the thing that i sought
validation from
as an adult and that will be true for
you no matter what it is
no matter if it's romantic affection no
matter if it's validation
no matter if it's money no matter what
it is the thing that invalidated you
when you were younger
will be this the thing that you seek
validation from as an adult and until
you understand
what that thing is it risks being the
number one thing
that can ruin your life i've like gone
through
every like corner of my childhood to try
and understand the things that made me
feel invalid
in order to understand some of the
forces that are in play
in my life right now as an adult and
honestly it has
liberated me i wrote in my diary one day
the reasons i'll go broke
and it was pretty much this it was
because i was broke
when i was a kid and because that
developed a really
you know psychological issue with money
where money for me became
a plaster it became the thing that would
make me feel the opposite to whatever
shame is
and i just think it's so important for
everyone to to think about the things
that happened when they were young
and to understand the forces that
invalidated them because if you don't
understand them and if you can't make
them conscious and
hold them out in front of you and
examine them they will control your life
subconsciously somewhere
and honestly i've got to be honest do i
think i'll ever really
overcome this unhealthy relationship i
had with money
i don't think i'll ever truly overcome
it completely
because it is so deeply hard-wired into
me
at a time in my life when i was so
impressionable and when every emotion
just seemed to cut more and carve into
me
but that's not really my aim my aim
isn't to overcome it my aim is to become
conscious of it
and if i can become conscious of it it
has less impact over me and fortunately
where i'm at in my life now i don't make
those stupid dumb decisions all of the
time
sometimes i make dumb decisions like i'm
not gonna pretend i'm some [ __ ] like
profit that you know lives their life
perfectly and always makes decisions
that are in line with their values
sometimes i do things to impress people
but it's like 99
less than i used to and that's because
i'm holding out
my sort of psychological relationship
with money in front of me
and i'm able to look at it and i'm able
to question myself and interrogate my
decisions against this known
flaw that i have in my psychology steve
why are you trying to buy a rolls royce
you don't really like rolls royces you
don't know anything about them because
you think oh yeah
because you think it's going to impress
somebody
because you think somewhere deep inside
of you that
child that had nothing will feel more
fulfilled if he has that range rover or
that rolls royce or that mansion
and whenever i go to make these big
decisions now
it's the first thing i think of so i
don't think i've overcome it
but i've definitely been able to
understand it and if you can understand
it if you can understand the thing that
invalidated you and your kid
that's as good as overcoming it and that
will help you stop seeking validation
from it as an adult
and that that will change your life
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you